では皆様よろしくお願いします
これからこのスリランカの文化のいろいろ博物館で展示がありますので
初めてスリランカのそういう古いものを国外に持っていったことで
日本は初めてだそうです
大使の話によると そういうことで
本当のところは今日は文化について喋らなくちゃいけないんですけどね
まあ一応私はまあなかなかどういうものは展示しているのか
まだ見てないんですね
だからなかなかそういうものについてはちょっと説明
今のうちはできませんですが
とにかくお釈迦様の教えは何なのかということを説明して紹介したいと思います
特にスリランカの文化といっても仏教文化ですから
その仏教文化を築いた教えは何なのかということを皆様に紹介したいと思います
このスライドにも出ているこの彫刻二つは
だいたい古いお寺に入る時
玄関にあるもので これは古い 10世紀あたり
12世紀あたりで作ったもので
コロンボのもの  これは持ってはいかれませんですからね
建物にあるものですから
で まずはブッダの教えと仏教という
何でしょうかね ブッダの教えは仏教でしょうね
スリランカの仏教徒にとっては
ブッダの教えが仏教なんです
それは釈尊により説かれた教えと
それに長老方がつけた注釈
ブッダの教えを基にして説法する
解説する説法になります
スリランカでは仏教といえば
まずお釈迦様の教えですね
それから お釈迦様の教えに
このインドから紀元前 2 世紀あたりから伝わってきた注釈書がありまして
それはパーリ語に 4 世紀あたりでパーリ語に翻訳されて
世界中使えるようにしましたけど
で これその注釈書と それからお坊さんたちがこの経典と注釈書をもとにして
いろいろ本を書いたり
説法したりしますね それを全部まとめてスリランカ人は仏教と呼ぶんですね
で 何しろお釈迦様の教えでなければ仏教ではないという立場なんです
しかし 日本では様々な開祖様が開発した教えと
現代に突き出される新興宗教も仏教になるので
ここで区別しておきます
ですから 日本の皆様方は仏教
仏教といっても 日本で使う意味とは違いますということだけ覚えておいてください
日本では誰でも何言ったっても仏教と言うんですよ
面白いことに 我は神様よとおっしゃっている方もいらっしゃいます
でも彼も仏教だというんですね
まるっきり邪教なんですけど
で そういうことだから
やっぱり日本では結構
一般的に まあただ宗教といえば仏教というぐらいにかな
わからないんで あまり真剣じゃないんですね
仏教といえば何でもいいやということなんですけど
私たちはそうじゃないんですよ
やっぱり仏教といえば
このこの中身がなければ仏教でなりませんと
で 聖書から引用しながら喋って
これは仏教というふうに我々は思いませんね
とにかく日本で仏教というと
結構いろんなものあるということ
あの犯罪者犯罪組織であったオウム真理教さえも
もう自分がシバ神やと言い張っているのにも関わらず仏教だというんだからね
だからまあどこまでか論理的かわかりませんだけど
それとは違います スリランカ人にとっては釈尊の教えですよ
釈尊の教え 例えば経典のごとく書いたものだったらすぐ捨てます
邪教やと 釈尊の教えに基づいて注釈することは可能です
自分の言うことは お釈迦様の言葉から引用して整理しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから我々子供の頃 説法を長老たちに教えてもらう時でも
もういい加減喋るなよと
何か喋るならば ちゃんとそれを整理する
証明する経典文句を言いなさいよと
だから全部できるだけ多くのことを暗記しておきなさいよと言われてるんです
もうかなり厳しく で 今の私たちはそんないい加減
自分の意見を言い張って
それがブッダの教えということは言わない
かなり怖いんですよ もうその点ではなかなか他のお坊さんたちは
批判するし お坊さんたちのところじゃないんですよ
普通の人々 ものすごく厳しい批判するんですよ
その中でも一番私が怖いのは
この田舎にいるおばあさん
おじいさんたちの批判なんですよ
知識人の批判はまあ何とも思わないんですけど
もう当てにもならないし
しかし この畑やって田んぼを作っているおじいさん
おばあさんたちの批判というのはかなり厳しいんです
それから しっかりとお釈迦様の教えに基づいて批判するんです
だから そういう一般の田舎の人々の批判っていうのは結構厳しくて
それによって仏教 ブッダの教えが結構純粋に守られているんですよ
本当に面白いところは
スリランカという国で
このエリートというインテリの人々よりも
仏教を純粋に大事に守って次の世代に伝えるということは
一般の人々がものすごくやっているんですよ
エリートはいろいろありまして
西洋かぶりということがよくありましてね
何でも西洋的にやろうではなくてといって
もうすぐ勝手に変えたりもする
だからまあ それからもう科学かぶりもあってね
科学者が何かいい加減何か言ったら
すぐそこを仏教と対照して
あれやこれやと言ったりするし
それで最近ではなくて
2年  3年前からすごくこの低次元的な
この何といいますか 暗示方法とかね
ヒプノシスマとかね そういう非科学的なものをもってブッダの教えが正しいと証明しようと思ったりして
すごくそれはインテリの人々がやっていることなんですよ
だから心理学を学んでますけど
この人に暗示かけて言うことは信頼性あるわけないんですけど
だからまあ そういうものにはインテリの方々あるいは知識人が惹かれますが
田舎のおじいさん おばあさんたちは見落とししないんで
そういうことは すごい論理的なんですよ
それからスリランカの仏教文化ということだから
ちょっと雑談いろいろ挿入してますが
これ何回も言ったエピソードで
誰も信じないんですけど
私はほんの短い時間が向こうの大学でちょこちょこっと教えていたんです
で それであの朝 ものすごい大量にファイルとかいろいろ持って
重くて本やら参考書ものすごく持ってバスに乗ろうとしていたんですよ
スリランカのバスというのはすごい乗りやすいもので
だいたい 40人乗れるものには 120人ぐらい乗ります
足の半分ぐらいつければもう大変すいませんということで
で どこでも窓でもどこでもぶら下がって
今はそこまでないんですけど
かなり 20年前の話ですからね
だから私はバスに乗らなかったら授業に遅れる
遅れるし だからちょっと裏手を遅くって
時間に来る運転手さんの顔をちょっと知るように
おいて だからその人は私を見たら
あのお坊さんだと知ってますから
140人乗っていたっても
一応バスは止めてくれるんです
で そこで待ってる時は
あのキリスト教系の信仰宗教の人々がビラを配っていたんですよ
そのビラは何書いてあったかというと
奇跡だ 奇跡だ 神の奇跡だとかね
目が見えない人はたちまち目が見えるんだ
耳が聞こえない人はたちまち耳が聞こえるんだ
ライ病はたちまち治るんだ
結核は瞬時に治るんだ
歩けない人は歩くんだという
この大奇跡をね 目の前に送りますからということで
午後 6時半で なんとか大きな公園がありまして
そちらでみんな集めてくださいというビラなんですね
そこで普通 この家を作ったりする
ある労働する人が ものすごい一般的な人で
おそらく学校に行っていないと思いますよ
だからそういう労働をやっていて
なんとか 1日の給料で生活している
収入で生活している人
で ズボンも履かないで
ただ腰巻きだけで その人にはビラ 1枚あげたんですね
その人はそれを見て あら
この連中にこんなことできるならば
なんでスリランカの結核病院に行って一発でみんな治してくれませんかと
それなら私も神様を信じますよと言って
紙 1枚捨てちゃったんですね
その瞬間 私は考えたのは
この人々は学校に行ってないかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様の教えの基本的な難しいところまで
自分の血液の中で遺伝の中に入ってるんだと
そう簡単に馬鹿にすることはできないんだと
私は大学で仏教哲学というちょっとカッコつけた名前で講義をやっていたんですけど
だから比較宗教を比較して
こういうわけで仏教と他の宗教は違いますよというためにかなり苦労するんですよ
あの人は何のことなく一言葉で
そこで私は結構勉強してるんだから
この論点 すごい頭に なるほど
すごいな この人はと ですから
そのポイントを明確に説明すると
やっぱり仏教から見れば客観的にしっかりした証拠がなければ信じてはいけないんですね
それ 仏教の特色の一つなんですね
はっきりした証拠欲しいんですね
60%の証拠あるんだったら放っておけと
否定することもできるんだけど
いわゆるペンディングにしなさいと
100%の証拠が必要なんですよ
それなら病院に 例えばライ病の患者さんがいるとするならば
ライ病であることははっきりしていますね
だってお医者さんが決めてるんだから
そこで神様のすごいパワーでライ病を治したならば
お医者様がもう退院させますからね
退院させる場合は お医者様がサインしますよ
治ったと それだったら誰にでも信じられます
やっぱり神の力ですよと
そうではなくて この俳優さんを雇ってね
歩けない人の役があるし
目が見えない人の役がある役があるし
耳が聞こえない人の役があるし
これでド派手に音楽を奏でてお祈りすると
まあ歩けない人にとっても
今立ってください 今 あなたに神の力が降りてますよと言って
あの人はもうやっとやっともう倒れながらなんとか立って
もう足が震えたりして
それでお祈りする人がもう大丈夫
大丈夫って体を触って
なんとか舞台に上がってもらって
これみんなハレルヤホサンナとかなんとか言ったりしてね
だからそういう演劇で
パフォーマンスで人の信仰っていうのはね
どうかなと いうところが
仏教ブッダが否定しているんですよ
ただ お釈迦様がこの教えをうのみにするなよと言っておっしゃったところで
である人々がね まあいろんな人が来て
あれ 私の宗教正しい 私の宗教正しい
私の宗教正しいって言うんだからね
私たち誰の教えも信じませんよと言ったら
お釈迦様 確かにあなた方はすごいんだと
その通りだと 信じる必要はないんだと
自分で調べなさいよと
どのように調べるかと
私は質問しますよと 例えば私は聞きます
あなたはどう思いますか？怒りは良いことだと思いますか？と
ただ相手が怒りは良くないねとか
ではどう思いますか？怒りをもとにして人が喋ったり行動したり考えて
その考え方 行為が良いと思いますかと
良いと思いませんよと
じゃあそれによって良い結果になると思います
幸せになると思いますか？そう思いませんよと
では 人が怒りをなく 慈しみで
ならばどうでしょうか
それはいいことだよと
慈悲心に基づいて考えたり
喋ったり 行動したりするならば
その人と周りが幸福になるかなれないかと
これは幸福になりますよと
と相手が答える それでお釈迦様は結論を出す
ですから 私は怒りをなくせと説くのだと
それで話が終わる 私を信じなさいということはないのです
そういうことで 相手にはっきりした証拠があって
認められるように 納得できるように語るということが
仏教の基本的なスタンスなんですね
だから結構論理的なんですよ
矛盾がないんですよ 例えば
たとえ神様の偉大なるパワーで
ライ病の患者さんが治ったとしたっても
なんでそもそもその人はライ病になったんですかね？そういう疑問が出てくるんですよ
それは神様に隠れて誰かがやったんですかね？では細菌やりました
で だから細菌のコントロールを神様にできないんでしょうかとかね
すべて創造したのは神様ではないかとか
そういう風にいろんな矛盾が出てくるんですよ
逆に人が病気になったり
不幸になったり いろんなことになるのは
いろいろ神様がそういう人々に何かメッセージを与えているんだそうと
そうすると 私がなんで私を選んだでしょうかと聞きたくなるんですよ
例えば ある子供が結核じゃなくて白血病になったりしますね
そうすると その家族に神様が何か教えてるんだと
なんでその家族を選んだんですかね
いくらなんでもお母さんが苦しんでますけどね
そういうことで ちょっと矛盾というものがありまして
仏教ではそういう矛盾は全くございません
で 次に行きますけど 釈尊の教えから脱出しないので
長い歴史の中で様々な変化が起きたが
基本的に一貫性があります
スリランカの仏教というのは起源からずっとあるもので
日本の仏教歴史を見ると結構変化が見られますけど
奈良時代とかね 鎌倉時代とかいろいろありますが
向こうはそれほとんどないんです
いろいろ変化はあるんですよ
もう戦略されたり いろんなことあったりして
仏教衰えたり また復活したり
またいろいろちょっと隠れたりとかあったんですが
基本的な教えは変わってないんです
出家はいくつかの宗派に分かれているが
それは社会的現象のみで
教えは厳密にテーラワーダ仏教になるのです
皆様は時々知っていると思いますけど
スリランカの出家のお坊さんたちの間では
この宗派というものがあるんですよ
日本の宗派とはちょっと違いますね
だからこちらのお坊様方何人かいますけど
いくつかの宗派のお坊様たちなんですよ
しかし 我々はもうただただ社会的なことで
もう何々という名前をつけて
何々家とか名前をつけてるような感じで
教えとしては微塵も変わったことはないんです
だからみんな随分仲良くいろいろ活動をやっているんです
それは日本の宗派の現象と比較すると結構違います
日本の宗派のように内容的に互い違いということは見られません
だからまあ 日本にも宗派があるんだ
スリランカの宗派があるんだということを言われても
これすごく違います スリランカにも宗派があるんですけど
みんな同じ教え 同じ習慣
何でももう 100%同じなんで
やっていること で だから何のこともなく仲良く一緒にいつでも行動する
日本では宗派によって教えが違う
すっごく違います それで一般人がすごく困るんです
何が仏教かとわからなくなります
で それから仏教文化というものは何なのかと
スリランカの文化は仏教文化だと言えるほど
ブッダの教えは根本的に民族の生活習慣に染みついています
スリランカ人が知っているか知らないかわかりませんだけど
やっていることはほとんど仏教文化なんです
仏教的なものなんです
仏教は嫌いだと言っている人でも
やっていることは結局は仏教と言われることなんです
キリスト教 イスラム教など後から入った宗教も仏教文化に染めてしまうんですよ
だから面白いことを何かスリランカにあるキリスト教の方々もイスラムの方々も
やはり外国の同じ宗教を信仰する人々とは微妙に違うんです
自分知らないうちに仏教文化に染めているんです
他宗教の方々は自分の独自性をしみじみと努力しないと仏教文化と同化してしまうんです
何のことなくいればどうなるかというと
この他宗教の方々は何のことなく仏教文化に同化してしまうんです
だから今もスリランカでちょっと民族争いといろいろありますけども
それ一つ原因はもうそういう激しい犯罪
テロ行為 そのようなところまでしない限りは
何のことなく仏教文化に同化してしまいます
これ不思議なことというのは
仏教の人々は強引に人に宣伝しない
宣教 伝教活動しないんです
あなた仏教徒になりなさい
誰にも言わないんです
仏教は仏教を知らない人々に教えてやろうと
全然その気持ちがないんです
ただ まあスリランカの坊さんちは怠けているかどうかわかりませんだけど
自分のお寺の周りの人々やら仏教の人々に説法するんであって
仏教を知らない人々に説法して
なんとか教えてあげようという気持ちはそれほどないんですね
で 在家の人々も友達はいっぱいいますけど
他の宗教の 全然その人々にずっと教えてあげようとまるっきりしないんです
なのに なんと不思議 何のことなく同化してしまいます
私もこちら日本に来てからも
いろんな宗教のスリランカの人々とね
前は結構仲良くしていますけど
どうもちょっと 2  3週間か 1ヶ月ぐらいになってくると
本人の宗教が何やらわからなくなっちゃうんです
いつでも悩み事があったら私のところに来て
そう言ったりするし 助けてもらったりするし
なんとなく同じ仲間になってしまうんです
仏教のそういうなんか変な力があるんですよ
で だからこれっていうのもその文化の強さであって
タイでもミャンマーでも
やっぱり一旦ブッダの教えが入ったら
この文化はものすごい染みついていくんです
至る所に それは何なのかと今日は一応説明したいと思います
仏教文化は排他的ではありません
他人との調和と共存を大事に思うんですよ
人を自分の教えに入ってもらうではなくて
どのようにこの人を仲良くすればいいかということが仏教的な生き方なんですね
だから対立起こらないんですよ
基本的には したがって
他宗教の異文化の影響を違和感なく受けてしまうんです
特に昔からもうスリランカの仏教の人々は
何の違和感もなくヒンドゥー教の寺院に行くんです
行ってお祈りするわ お供え物をするわ
祝福してもらうわ ヒンドゥー寺院でヒンドゥーの人々と一緒に
あのちょっとちょっと品のない踊りやりますけど
変な踊りをやってるわ
何でも一緒にやるんですよ
だからあんた仏教徒ではないかと言ったら
だから別にという感じなんです
だからこの あんまりこのまあイスラム教のモスクにはおそらく行かないだろうと思いますけど
イスラム教はすごい排他的だからね
中に入れてくれません
それ以外はどこにでも行きます
教会にも私も行きましたからね
何回何回も教会に もう神父さん知っていて
ある若い神父さんが 自分が一人前の神父として認定する儀式がありますって
私はこの日で この日でこの儀式がやりますよと言ったら
カトリック教の本山なんですけど
スリランカの 私は私も行きますよと
行って 何のことなく一番前の席に座ってね
堂々と私だけ一人で 別に何のこともないんです
だからまあ このそれは仏教のこの柔軟性で
だからなかなかまあうまくいってます
仏教文化は時代の流れとともにスムーズに変わっていくんです
だから我々はこの仏教文化っていうのは
この激しく攻撃しない
何者とも 若者がいろんな派手なファッションとかなんとかするんだからといって
カトリック教みたいにこんなのは良くない
あれは良くないと仏教は言わないんです
男の男たちが女のような女装をしていたっても
女性の方々はもう男のように服装を変えていたっていいんじゃないか
お前ら若者たちだからってそんな感じ
まあいい加減にしろよとか言うんですけど
それは批判的でも何のこともないんです
だから時代の流れと一緒にスムーズに進んでいくことは
仏教文化にはできるんです
文化と独立して ブッダの教えが変わることなく続くのはちょっと不思議です
それで我々は時代によって変わるんですよ
例えばスリランカの私は今
最近調べたところで 私は若い頃聞いた説法と現代説法のやり方
結構違いますね それは現代人にアピールして喋るんですよ
しかし 中身はもう変わらないんです
中身は変わらないんです
そこはちょっと不思議なんです
若者にアピールしようと思って
ブッダの教えを変えようとしないんです
そこは他の宗教の方々も学んだ方がいいところなんですよ
日本とスリランカの仏教ということで
スリランカの仏教徒は仏教と仏教文化の差は気にしません
おそらく知らないでしょうと思います
スリランカ人が仏教と文化
仏教文化ってあんまりわからないんです
よくよく仏教だ仏教だというのは文化なんです
それは学問的に見ればかなり違いますけど
まああまりわからないところがあるんです
しかし 日本には日本の文化があります
外来の文化はいらないんです
私はこれ言ったのは もう明治時代でも
かなり偉い方々がスリランカから純粋にテーラワーダ仏教を日本に紹介しようとは思ったんです
その当時で もう想像できないほどものすごい立派なお坊様方はスリランカにいたんです
このイギリス人にも仏教を教えて
もうヨーロッパにもテーラワーダ仏教を広げるように活動したお坊さんたちなんです
当時で日本からも行ったんですけど
何人かが しかし 真面目に修行して
真面目にすべて学んで
もう私たち 私から見てもすごい
こちらも教えてもらいたいぐらいすごいことを学んできたんですけど
日本でうまくいかなかったんですよ
で 私の個人的な考えは
なぜあれほど立派な方々に日本で仏教
また日本の方々でしょうに
できなかったというと
この仏教文化とブッダの教えというところはもう一緒になっているんですね
それはちょっとうまくいかないんですよ
それで私は明確に仏教と文化を切って分けて
日本に仏教を教えているんです
文化は日本の方々は自分の文化で結構ですと
だから スリランカでお坊さん見たら
随分手を合わせて丁寧に挨拶をする
日本の方々はそうしなくても私は一向に気にしない
する必要もないと したってもやり方わからないんだから
まあうるさいなと という態度なんです
で やっぱり日本の方々には日本の文化がありまして
その文化の中に普遍的な
絶対変わらない真理であるブッダの教えを入れてあげれば
もうそこでこの国もすごい繁栄して
精神的に繁栄して豊かになるだろうというのが私の個人的な立場なんですね
今 何年も続けてブッダの教え教えたんであって
スリランカ仏教を教えたわけじゃないんです
しかし 日本に滞在するスリランカの仏教徒たちが
やっぱりお寺に行っちゃうと
この文化的なことをやりたがるんですよ
で いろいろ文化的なお祭りをやりたがるんですね
やっぱりこれは日本の方々と一緒には
例えば この五月六月の満月はポソン祭というものを我々はやってます
かなり派手に満月をやるんですよ
それは何なのかというと
スリランカに仏教を伝来したことを思って念じてやっている派手な宗教お祭りなんです
かなり派手にやります
で 日本ではもうその六月の満月は派手に法要をやりますと言ったっても
何のためということ あれ
スリランカに仏教を伝来した日にちだよ
だから関係ないでしょうということになるんです
で その代わりに我々は五月になってくると
お釈迦様の誕生と成道をお祝いするんですね
それなら日本でもあまり日本でやったっても構いませんし
それよりは日本では花祭りってお釈迦様の誕生をお祝いする別な文化があるんですね
だからこの花祭りは お釈迦様の教えに基づいてお祭りやればどうでしょうかというふうな立場ですね
私の場合は だから 文化と教えが一応私はちゃんと線を引いて分けてます
時代の流れによって変化する必要は全くない
ブッダの教えは日本のみならず人類の役に立つものだと思います
そんなもので説明する必要ないんで
次に行きます